zwei leuchtende Herzen im Stadtzentrum
seit kurzem umarmt St Petersburg mit
dieser Skulptur das ukrainische Mariupol
das sind unsere neuen Territorien wir
sind Partnerstädte unsere Stadt hilft
mariopol beim Wiederaufbau
wer Mario Pool zerstört hat hören wir
sie nicht erklären wir sind hier mit
Alexander Budberg verabredet
stadtteilabgeordneter und Jurist etwas
abseits des Denkmals und der Polizisten
in Zivil erklärt Alexander wie heikles
ist Kritik zu äußern
Menschen befinden sich in Haft wegen
ihrer Worte weil sie ihren Gedanken
gegen den Krieg Ausdruck verliehen haben
[Musik]
das hat nicht die Dimensionen wie in der
stadienzeit es ist ein selektiver
er selbst bereitet sich darauf vor das
Land zu verlassen sollte es zu brenzlig
für ihn werden
kennengelernt haben wir Alexander
letzten September
Putin ließ in Moskau die Annektion von
vier ukrainischen Gebieten feiern
[Applaus]
patriotische Hochstimmung
angeleiteter Jubel für Alexander
Ausdruck dunkelster Entwicklungen zu
denen er nicht schweigen will wir
erleben den wahrscheinlich
dramatischsten Moment seit 1991 in
Russland wurde ein faschistisches Regime
gebildet
jetzt im Schatten des Krieges bekämpft
Russland die letzten gesellschaftlichen
Freiheiten er lässt Zensurgesetze
verbietet Menschenrechtsorganisationen
wer anders denkt wer anders liebt als
der Staat es will wird kriminalisiert
Carina und ihre Partnerin Betrieben in
St Petersburg das Rainbow Café
Treffpunkt für die LGBT-Community und
alle die Lust auf Kuchen hatten
dort stand die Bar da wo jetzt die
Getränke stehen da war die Theke
mittlerweile mussten sie schließen die
Leute hätten sich nicht mehr getraut zu
ihnen zu kommen seit Kriegsbeginn er
kennt Carina ihre Stadt kaum wieder
die Menschen haben sich verändert die
Stadt hat sich verändert
die Leute sind eingeschüchtert
verängstigt verschlossen wortkarg und
brutal geworden
im November dann hat Russland die
Gesetze gegen die sogenannte
lgbt-propaganda verschärft
aufklärungsmaterialien queere Kunst oder
gleichgeschlechtliches Händchen halten
in der Öffentlichkeit die Gesetze sind
so schwammig formuliert dass für all das
theoretisch Geldstrafen drohen ein
Ablenkungsmanöver der Regierung sagt
Carina
eine Sensation ein Rummel war nötig um
die Blicke vom Krieg abzulenken eure
Söhne eure Kinder tötet man da und
anstatt sich dagegen zu erheben winken
sie froh mit den Händchen und rufen wie
gut es doch ist wir haben jetzt keine
LGBT Bewegung mehr ach das ist doch
lächerlich
manchmal habe sie Suizidgedanken erzählt
Carina viele ihrer Freunde haben
begonnen zu trinken um zu vergessen
Angst um den Job Angst vor der Zukunft
Angst davor zu leben wie man ist dass
die Russinnen und Russen sich aus dieser
Lage befreien werden glaubt Carina nicht
seien wir ehrlich die russischen
Menschen sind feige sehr feige sie
werden nichts ändern und wissen Sie
warum nein jeder sitzt da und denkt ich
habe einen Kredit ich habe eine Hypothek
ich muss mein Kind in die Schule
schicken ich habe irgendeinen Job und
ich bin nicht bereit dies alles zu
verlieren
zurück zu Alexander er will uns einen
Ort zeigen der droht vergessen zu werden
obwohl 400.000 Opfer bei der Weltkriege
hier begraben liegen Alexander stellt
uns Ilja Popov vor seit 20 Jahren kämpft
der dafür dass der Friedhof seine Würde
zurückerhält
[Musik]
für uns in St Petersburg dem früheren
Leningrad sind die Erinnerungen an den
Krieg und die Blockade durch die
Wehrmacht heilig vielleicht liege ich
falsch aber ich glaube das russische
Volk befindet sich jetzt wieder in so
einer Situation wie im zweiten
weltkriegler
über eine Million Menschen starben
während der Leningrader Blockade als die
Wehrmacht die Stadt 29 Monate lang
umzingelte und aushungerte
[Musik]
die Erinnerungen an die Opfer die Helden
und den Sieg der Sowjetarmee über Hitler
Deutschland sind zentral in Russland
darauf baut die Propaganda wenn sie
behauptet heute werde wieder gegen Nazis
gekämpft diesmal in der Ukraine
zum heutigen Tag sehen wir reale
Erscheinungen von Narzissmus und
natürlich erfüllt unser Land die Bitten
jener Menschen die dort leiden boah das
geht um zwei vom Geiste und von den
historischen Wurzeln her sehr ähnliche
Völker von dem das eine von einem
volksfeindlichen Regime geführt wird und
in einen anti-russischen Zustand
versetzt wurde
Alexander will die Männer überzeugen
dass nicht die ukrainische Regierung das
Problem ist sondern die russische
acht Jahren bombardiert wird ist wohl
normal aber wer hat den Krieg im Don was
denn angefangen
wir sollten uns nicht provozieren lassen
gehen wir vielen Dank
nimmt seine Mitbürger in Schutz
wenn Sie diese Fragen stellen
bringen sie die Leute in eine sehr
schwierige Position
das verstehe ich das ist auch etwas was
ich im vergangenen Jahr verändert hat es
ist schwerer geworden offen zu sprechen
sehr schwer zu sprechen ja
Alexander lässt das nicht gelten seine
Diagnose viele Russinnen und Russen
seien von einem Virus befallen und
dieser Virus heiße Propaganda
[Musik]